all of that force gets unleashed like
that and you can move boulders or do a
lot of damage to an enemy while they
can't hit you never again
No
[Music]
from the get-go there is one sequence
out of the whole video that I
specifically had my eyes on I was like I
want to do that whole sequence that was
specifically the stasis sequence where
Linc shoots out the CLO beam and freezes
the juggernaut in place
can't shoot he can't move he's frozen in
time but he can take on damage in that
time and it stores up kind of like
creating this powder keg was a as Linc
keeps shooting the guy and all that
energy that he absorbed is unleashed all
at once and he goes flying backwards
into the wall the newest Zelda game run
through the wild came on the switch one
of my favorite games ever it's so good
oh my gosh so good
anyway there's an ability in that game
where you can freeze objects and later
on you can freeze enemies enable the
ability and you hit it and then whatever
thing you freeze has like these golden
glowing chains shootout it and now in
the game they kind of like fade away but
they look cool enough I'm gonna keep it
for the whole sequence so you freeze a
boulder you punch the boulder a few
times with all those punches that you
hit over and over again build up so that
all of that force gets unleashed like
that and you can move boulders or do a
lot of damage to an enemy while they
can't hit you first things first I want
to isolate this juggernaut from the
background and I did that by using the
rotor brush tool boom
empty after rotoscoping i duplicated now
i'm trying to add this find edges
effects unsharp mask is great for
bringing out detail of different sizes
so using three different instances of
unsharp mask boom now there's a lot more
detail from there you apply find edges
boom and that's what it looks like right
off the bat actually just inverted boom
so we went all inside parts to be kind
of darker and black and we tint it so
just black and white we want to remove
all color from it because we're gonna
add the color back in using videocopilot
color vibrance one of my favorite
plugins it's more advanced than tint the
thing that is nice about vc color
vibrance is that it doesn't just tense
everything one color or not it actually
will gradiate the color a little bit
depending on how gray that color is and
that bumped up the lows a little bit and
another set of levels to brighten it up
but here's the problem well all this
noise also gets accentuated so the noise
is becoming an edged need
want that so by using a little bit of
fast blur you get rid of the noise I
starts going away because it's no longer
edges for the find edges to find if I
turn back on my rotoscope layer
it's just laid on top of it that's
that's all it's doing so then I had a
second line where I change the setting a
little bit so you'll actually see him
getting brighter but that's just the
leftover keyframes I have from gets
brighter every time it gets shot yeah
find edges is a really cool way to add
an energy effect to a person just have
all their outlines just kind of glowing
on top of that I added like a BG glow eg
background BG stands from background
I also added this this bevel edges thing
I turn off everything except for that
bevel edges basically just kind of you
know what a bevel is Carmichael of
raised engraving light way of doing like
3d and that's kind of what's going on
here so you can see how it like the
lights coming from this side if we had
the edges bright and the other side the
edges dark this was one of those little
creative things that I thought was was
an interesting addition so adding the
bevel edges miss edge circles around his
rotoscoped outline here and then I
tinted that end up with like this
flashing sort of effect but the thing
that really like makes this a Zelda
reference are the chains when he gets
frozen in time have I been to Santa's
workshop did his summer camp there never
again lets mrs. Claus for the chains I
actually used a program called element
3d it's a plugin for after effects from
Video Copilot Video Copilot typically
makes some of the coolest plugins out
there an element 3d has this cool thing
works like you can create a null object
that is a 3d object that's connected to
all the settings for your 3d model so
you don't have to go through and change
all like the rotation and position
settings within the plug-in itself you
just move this little no object it's
like it's like a controller for the 3d
model basically just take a 3d model of
a chain delete it all the links except
for one rotated it offset it and I did
that like 20 times and made this really
long linked thing in cinema 4d I save
that out as a different file and open
that with in After Effects element 3d so
using just the 3d null object regular
After Effects I'm able to move these
chains around inside of the viewport of
After Effects so this glow kinda
coming out of the back of them here
every time you get shot in the game
there's an arrow that shows the vector
that is gonna move across when it stays
in but for this it's just going directly
backwards cuz it's getting shot from the
front so instead of having an actual
like cartoon arrow sticking out of the
back you want to figure out a way to
interpret that into a real-world medium
I basically just took the entire layer
of the juggernut off set it add a glow
CC radial fast blur all that stuff but
of course we also still have all the
hints that are taking place and for
those use a bunch of Sparks and I did
that tracers because it looked like he
was just malfunctioning like sparking
all over the place so I did add tracers
which are literally just an orange line
and then from there does I just try to
put it as many different like spark
elements as I could to have like debris
flying through it it's a pretty sweet
shot considering it's 17 frames long
it's 3/4 of a second I don't think we're
gonna finish on time what do you mean I
just used the the shatter effect for the
chains too so the final note that Adrian
had for this is he wanted it to be gory
he wanted to be brutal so I added in a
whole bunch of blood let's splatter on
the wall some blood mist in the air what
ties us all together and really makes it
feel intense is the crazy displacement
map displays a master like oh they're my
favorite things in After Effects